all right so hey guys um thanks for
coming to our second class um today we
have the pleasure of welcoming aishia
he's a senior research scientist at
Google mine where he works on the
robotics team um he received his PhD
here actually um working with um Sylvio
salaries and Stanford vision and
learning lab as well as
leonit um and his mission is to build
intelligent embodied agents um that can
interact with complex and unstructured
real world environments um with
applications home robotics um recently
has he has been exploring the use of um
Foundation models um for robots decision
making and action Generation Um so now
I'll hand it off to
P um hi everyone um I'm super happy to
be here and happy to be back I graduated
from here two years ago and now I'm a
research scientist at Google deep mind
uh I work on the robotic team and today
I will be talking about low-level
embodied intelligence with Foundation
models so uh it's definitely an
interesting topic and I will introduce
what is embodied intelligence and what
is low-level embodied intelligence and
how we can um accelerate the building of
them with the foundation
models um all right so why are we
working on embodied intelligence so
embodied intelligence is an integral
part of um artificial elligence and it's
an important Milestone to um artificial
general intelligence and it has a lot of
use cases like for example we all hope
we have a home robot that can be our
home um 247 and clean the home for us or
um um clean up our um messy room or cook
for us or taking care of our our uh
aging family members so we are not quite
there yet in fact we are quite far from
it uh that is because our intelligence
is currently mostly in the the virtual
world so we have ai agent that can help
us draft emails or write eloquent essays
but they are not super good at
interacting with the messy uh real world
unstructured complex environment that
human resides in so just to give you
guys a couple examples of how messy the
the real world can be and how hostile it
could be to to robotics I want to show
you a curious mistake or curious error
uh from one of our robots so the task is
to put the uh put the Cod can in the
sink and watch what the robot do the
robot grab the Coke can and open the tab
so um this is kind of dangerous but it's
kind of interesting right because we
never expect it would uh do something
like that it's just from random noise it
it it starts to open the top and the
water starts to come out so for a an an
agent to have this type of physical
intelligence it need to understand the
effect of its actions and what is
so-called a world model so people have
been complaining that language model so
far don't have a world model so it
doesn't understand geometry doesn't
understand spatial relationship of
objects or the effect of actions
basically how object will will move
according to physical laws so uh we are
not quite there yet in another case so
uh this is our robot that is ready to
deliver a can or throw away again but as
you could see we have this Pro
pre-programmed behavior of tucking the
arm behind and in doing that the can is
upside down so if there's any liquid in
a can it will spill and damage the robot
so it's another example of real world is
really complex and there are a lot of
things to model and um in order for our
robots to have this sort of ambient
intelligence it really need to
understand a lot of very Nuance um uh
details of the environment and
understanding the physics physical laws
and understanding um effect of its
actions um how do we do that there are
many ways to achieve embodied
intelligence actually throughout my PhD
study I've been fascinated by this idea
of uh creating interactive environments
basically let agent explore in this
interactive environments basically
create environments that are complex
enough so so that if the agent need to
survive in such environment it must
develop intelligence so it's a
ecological view of perception and agency
and is popularized by American
psychologist James J Gibson so um he has
a famous quote ask not what what is
inside your head but what your head is
inside of so human learned this type of
embodied intelligence human is able to
manipulate objects e effortlessly one
because of evolution second because the
the childhood experience we have been
playing with this toy we have been
interacting with this toy and watch the
physical effect so that we learn um and
similarly we can give robot uh a safe
play pan so they can explore in those uh
environment and interact with
environment and play and watch the uh
effect of actions and effectively
understand how to manipulate those
objects um so I have been um developing
this uh simulation environment uh one of
which is called Gibson environment which
is published as cvpr uh it's mainly
aiming at simulating the visual World
faithfully and also simulate physical
world to some extent so we we build this
environment which is a scanned
environment from a lot of houses and
then an agent we can spawn an agent in
that in this case a humanoid agent and
the agent can learn learn to walk or to
run in this environment and simulate all
this perception information so we can
can create a perception action Loop uh
for this for this agent and similarly we
can put other types of agent in this
environment in this case a little a
little cart and we can also put
quadruped or or this ant into this
environment so essentially we create um
an environment where we can simulate a
perception for for the agent and then we
can create a neuron Network to map the
perception to action and uh this way we
achieve some sort of physical
intelligence it's mostly for uh navigate
navigation and
Locomotion this is not enough um so in
this case the the the environment is one
monolithic piece of mesh as you can see
the the agent run into the wall and it
it bounc back so there's no articulation
in this environment so it's not
simulating the full complexity of the
environment so the the the things uh
that we can do with our agent is rather
limited so that's what why we create
other simulation environment one of
which is I Gibson environment which is
called interactive Gibson so uh what we
do is we create we we again scan a lot
of uh real world houses and then we
convert them to uh CAD assets basically
mesh assets that are interactable in
this case we have a simulated agent that
go into the environment and then close
all the drawers um so we are able to do
that because we we model the complexity
of the world a little bit more we go
beyond just modeling the visual world we
we start to model physics a little bit
more
basically um modeling the degree of
freedom in environment and and our agent
can do more than just navigating around
so um we can go even further so we can
even model more degree of freedom and
our agent can develop more complicated
Behavior such as unloading a dishwasher
and find a bow or uh take out a bow and
put it on the table so as we scale up
the complexity of the environment we we
are able to um learn much more
complicated skills um in in simulation
and that's one way to achieve embodied
intelligence uh which is to build
complex enough simulation
environment um not just the my research
but the entire field of computer vision
is undergoing a paradigm shift so
previously we are focusing on internet
AI we cured a lot of Internet data sets
to uh study problems like classification
segmentation and detection basically all
these computer Vis problems now we focus
a lot more on embodied AI uh which is
adding the the action Dimension to the
problem that we are studying problems
like visual navigation manipulation
rearrangement embody question answering
instruction following um and the
simulators replace in some in some some
sense replace the original role of data
sets one thing that doesn't change uh
which is the data is still super
important we are still relying on a
large amount of data to uh learn this
intelligent Behavior no matter it's from
a static data set or from a
simulator so um learning in simulation
can can take a lot of interactions so
just give you um an example we create
this uh ibson environment and we want to
learn a behavior called go into a room
through a closed door so this is a
rather simple Behavior which I can show
on the top right of the screen so the
agent need to stop in front of the door
it need to stop at the right distance if
it's stop too close to the door it
cannot extend its arm if it's too far it
cannot open the door and then it
basically open the door let me play this
again open is a door when there's enough
clearance it will go into the door
however it takes about 50,000 episodes
or 1 25 million environment interactions
to learn this type of behavior um this
is because we are using model free
reinforcement learning the agent is
exploring this environment it could
really push any point it could rather
stop at any point so um we we give it a
reward function to go into the room but
it's very rare that it will stumble upon
this
Behavior I would like to argue with
Foundation models we can do a lot uh a
lot more different right so what do you
what do you do nowadays you just ask a
hbt how do you go into your room through
a closed door and it will say open the
door walk through the door so this is a
this is a gross simplification of the
problem of course um it it's the problem
is not that simple but what I'm just
saying is that we can leverage a lot of
semantic prior from the the foundation
models so if we if we if we really like
data if we really need a lot of data the
foundation model is a compressed version
of the entire data and it's a know base
that you can quiry and to accelerate the
development of Robotics of course
simulation and real world data is still
super super important but maybe we can
uh get the best of both worlds we can
use Foundation models plus uh a limited
amount of simulation of real world data
um so that's what I'm going to talk
about
today so where are we in terms of
foundation models plus robotics so our
team at Google deepmind has been
piloting in Foundation model Plus
robotics so we developed Advanced
planning high level planning algorithm
one of the first is called Palm Sayan it
is an algorithm that can parse a user
command so so here is a demo here's a
scenario here is the user command I
spill my Coke on the table how would you
throw it away and bring me something to
help clean and it's quiring a large
language model uh which is given a score
uh um highlighted in blue and there's
also an affordance score the affordance
will tell you whether an action at a
given state is possible it's argumenting
the language model to give you only
possible things so essentially it is
doing the planning doing the semantic
planning with a language model but it's
also taking into consideration what it
can do so it's not just a um outputting
the like language model are tend to
hallucination uh it it doesn't
hallucinate it only give you what is
possible for the robot to do and what is
actionable for the robot and the robot
is doing the thing that is advancing the
long Horizon task progress and also each
task is executed by a low Lev policy
here it doesn't quite uh clean the the
the table uh because uh we haven't added
this to the low level skill but imagine
there is a low level skill to clean the
table it will finish the entire
thing uh what is the Lo of policy used
to here the Lo of policy used to here is
robotic Transformer one uh rt1 it's our
team's homegrown transform forer
essentially we collect a large data set
of uh human demonstrations we put a
Transformer um and we we train train it
on uh this large data set of expert
trajectories it is able to do about 700
tasks with 97% success rate so um and it
gener it has interesting generalization
Behavior it can operate in a new kitchen
it has never seen before so which is
showing um there is a successful recipe
to apply foundation models in robotics
so that's roughly where are we in terms
of foundation model plus robotics um and
I would I will I will um talk about a
few new works that is bringing this to
uh the next level so um actually U my
teammate Ted give a talk of foundation
models plus robotics at the beginning of
this this year um it's also this class
cs25 I highly recommend it it's uh it's
available on YouTube I actually watch it
last night so that I don't repeat um
some of the the contents but what he
basically mentioned is that we um he
revealed our team's progress in terms of
building this robot robotic Foundation
models and we have had a lot of some
somewhat detour and now we we sort of
figured out a recipe so in 2021 to 2022
is how we scale to many tasks with
demonstrations how do we collect a large
amount of data uh in fact um about
100,000 U demonstrations and we tried
different ways to do it we tried the
behavior cloning we tried imitation
learning plus reinforcement learning and
um some other ways or combining them
with language models such as Sean in
2022 to 2023 uh is about how we can
leverage Foundation models to accelerate
robotics we really see a proliferation
of um using Foundation models to
accelerate robotics uh both on the high
level planning and low level control
probably leaning more towards the high
level
planning so if the recipe Works um so so
the recipe is essentially uh combine a
large scale diverse offline data set
which uh with with high capacity
architecture such as a Transformer and
using language as a universal glue so
this will be the the recipe to build
Foundation models for
robotics okay so if this recipe Works
what do we do what do we do next
essentially we just uh let's just scale
everything to to others of magnitude and
uh and be done with it and and and solve
Robotics and and and guess what that's
what we did so that's the end of the
lecture maybe we can cut this a little
bit short um and that that's a joke
that's that's not happening um so we we
we are still on our way uh on our quest
to solve lowlevel embodied intelligence
when I talk to people uh that you can
use Foundation models to uh uh to do
robotics uh their reaction would be it's
mostly doing highle reasoning it doesn't
do the lowlevel uh manipulation really
well uh and that that's for a reason
like one of the reason is there's a
morava paradox uh morava Paradox is
observation that in artificial
intelligence and Robotics contrary to
traditional assumptions or our
intuitions reasoning requires very
little computation but S motor control
and perception skills require enormous
comput sources that is because as U
biological creators we um we we acquire
the sensory model skills through
Evolution um this is very different so
we don't we might not be able to um like
reason or do large amount of large scale
computation but this uh sensory model
control is integral to our survival so
it's it's essentially already learned in
our DNA but in in robotics it's a little
bit different so the the the ch tips are
very good at doing reasoning and
computation but they are not super good
they haven't experienced the world they
haven't acquired the sensory model
skills that is uh necessary for them to
uh do task in the real world here is
example when the the the uh computer
beat the Caspar of basically the human
champion in chess uh there is another
robot arm moving the chest piece it can
beat the human champion in uh in chess
but there are still some need to move
the chest piece similarly in in the
alphao moment when lisador was beaten by
alphao there's still someone who is
moving the chest piece for them it's not
a robot doing that so this is showing
the reasoning is the hard things are
easy and the easy things are
hard there's another thing that prevent
us from like using Foundation models
more prevalently more in a larger skill
in robotics which is the training data
bias like the training data of
Foundation models or large language
models are mostly language tasks so it's
perhaps not that surprising it knows how
to clean up a kitchen because maybe
there are W Wiki how articles teaching
you how to clean up a kitchen or to do
something in a procedural way but there
is no Wiki how articles teaching you how
to move your finger 5 centimeters to the
left because people just don't uh say
that people don't write that down so
there is very limited amount of uh this
lowlevel Control Data in Lar anguage
model training cpra so we do have a lot
of challenges in bringing the foundation
models to a lower level so that's what I
mean by lowle embodied
intelligence so uh any any questions so
far also I want to make this quite
interactive so there is any questions
feel free to interrupt me
anytime all right if not we can uh we
can continue so there are a couple
challenges of using large language
models for lowle control U as I just
mentioned men the first thing is lack of
data so we only have um perhaps 100,000
episodes uh of um of human demonstration
data and takes about 13 robots 17 months
to collect so it's a huge amount of
effort on the country large language
models are trained on the order of a
thousand billion tokens pal a smaller
Palm was trained on 780 billion
parameter uh 780 billion tokens and the
L one is trained uh the the the
following the chinchilla rule you would
need to train on 1.35 trillion tokens so
it's a huge amount of
um discrepancy between how much data we
can achieve in robotics and how much uh
we can get in large language models so
we will always be bounded by robotic
data so can we maybe we can scale on
other fronts maybe we can keep the
robotics data the same and then we can
scale on on other fronts like maybe we
can scale the pretraining mix of text
and image or maybe image and text pairs
maybe we can build this this cake and
the robotics data is just a cherry on
top of it and we can scale the
foundation really really well um some of
my my work that I'm going to talk about
today actually reuse the rt1 data we
don't collect new data for rt2 but we
want to do more things with the same
amount of
data um the Second Challenge is um kind
of related to the first challenge
language models lacks an interface for
lowle control if you ask a language
model how do you make a robot dog stand
up on two feet it will tell you a lot of
things that sounds reasonable sounds
plausible it will tell you the robot
dog's torso is upright balance over to
hind feet and standing shoulder width
apart this is great this is all great
but we cannot put it on the
robot um on on on the other on the other
hand maybe we can ask language model to
write control code to directly control
the robot but usually that requires you
to curate an API that is friendly to the
language model if I directly ask it to
give you my join angles to make the
robot stand upright it will not give you
the right thing because it doesn't have
enough context so essentially um large
language models don't speak robot
language uh can we actually find the the
right robot language can we find the
interface between large language models
and robot control or can we just treat
Robot action as another language so
that's what we want to find
out so um in today's agenda I will be
talking about lowlevel embod
intelligence with Foundation models it's
uh separated into two parts and it's
addressing the two challenges that I
have just mentioned part one is about
model consolidation uh joint scaling and
positive transfer so I have to put them
in one uh part because they are somewhat
related and part two is developing new
interface of large language
models so uh what do I mean by model
consolidation model consolidation uh yes
question yeah I just ask why you use and
for
generating L
code
description
yeah yeah that's a great question so the
question is why cannot we find tun
language model to directly output low
level code um and or like robot actions
so I will be talking about rt2 which
does somewhat similar to that it
fine-tune language model to Output
action as a language uh to find to
Output our action representation uh
there are certain downsides to that like
for example you would need to collect
additional data for to find a language
model um so either we can find T that or
we can use a language model zero shot if
you find the right interface which I
will talk about a little bit in a part
two without find
yeah so uh the model consolidation is
essentially we can do the high level
reasoning and low level control in one
model and Joint scaling is not only we
we scale the robot data which is
expensive we also scale um the the the
pr trining data or we already start from
a pre-trained vision language model and
a positive transfer is model benefiting
from diverse uh joint training across
internet scale language vision and
vision language domains uh combined with
robotics so uh this is a continuation of
the the the axis that Tad get Drew in
his previous talk so we can see there is
a trend so so this uh visualization
basically highlights some of the work on
our team and uh each each each work each
column is basically a robotic system
that is able to do both high level
reasoning and lowle control so
previously we need to uh have separate
models for each thing previously uh in
the initial release of Sean the planning
is done by a large language model and
affordance is done by um the affordance
is done by um a QT op like policy uh
trained with Sim real so um and the low
LEL low level policy is robotic
Transformer one so it's it's each model
doing its dedicated thing and uh uh we
need to train each model differently and
perhaps with different type of data and
later we have q Transformer which
unifies which is a kind of a offline RL
method uh that is leveraging Transformer
architecture so it's it's a
high-capacity architecture it can train
on both positive data and negative data
and with that we we able to get a policy
uh that is Al also understanding
affordances so we can unify the low Lev
policy and affordances but the planning
is still a large language model and then
we have py uh which is a vision language
model uh which is a large language model
also trained on Vision language domain
so the P can do planning and affordance
in just a one model but the low level is
still using rt1 and finally we unify
everything together like there is rt2
which I'm going to talk about today that
can do both high level planning to some
extent uh generating affordance and do
lowlevel uh policies so behind the model
consolidation is the consolidation of
tasks we can represent every task as a
Vision Plus text to text uh task so it's
a it's a really Universal representation
of the task and then with that you can
train it really on using a lot of data
and you can see positive transfer
basically learning learning affordance
can also tell you uh how to achieve a
task like like there there are transfer
between tasks when you pull all the
tasks
together so to understand this join
scaling and to understand the model
consolidation we need to um understand
palm e a little bit so palm e is
embodied multimodal language model it's
based on the palm architecture so Palm
is a large language model we made some
adaptation on the architecture so it can
understand multimodel input
so it's it is basically one model um
that is able to take in multimodal input
so um in large language models each word
is tokenized and tokenized and getting
this this embedding of this um words and
then that is feed fed into a large
language model so in pal what we do is
instead of using words we can use
multimodal tokens so the multimodal
tokens Can come from a vision Lang can
come from a vision Transformer a viit or
it can come from uh robot sensory data
so every um every multimodel
token then we map it to the text
embedding space um we basically train a
a linear a fine transform between the
multimodal token and the the text in
beding space and then we can treat um
the multimodal token as words as well so
essentially we have a language model as
as as a solid base and then we start to
adapt it to understand multimodal tokens
so this is quite interesting because we
don't it doesn't require a ton of
adaptation or fine-tuning for it to
understand uh multimodal input it just
aligns naturally to the multimodal input
such as images I will show a couple of
examples of what they can do and and we
can train the same way as training large
language models so essentially we can
reuse the same infrastructure and
training algorithm and everything uh to
train this P me um a couple other things
we we find along the way is positive
transfer uh which I will share in a
little bit so um I guess here I also
want to mention uh P me is one of the
largest model we have explored so far it
has 562 billion parameters which is by
concatenating the the Palm 540 billion
parameters and the 22 billion VI and we
find a lot of uh emerging capabilities
of these models that is we we haven't um
uh expected during training time but
really we can prompt these models and
ask you to do interesting things we have
also explored uh using neuros sing
representation basically an object
Centric
representation um to and fed into into
pal so um object Centric representation
assigns one token to each
object and we find this representation
is super helpful for robot planning
tasks because traditional viit
representation is based on grid and it
doesn't have a full understanding of
like objects and their relationships uh
we have done a ex um extensive study on
the the scaling performance and the
catastrophic forgetting performance um
and all other uh interesting experiment
in in the paper so please refer to the
paper for more so here I'm just showing
some interesting uh qualitative examples
of um or some emerging capability of
Tomy that we found out so first we found
this model has some reasoning capability
you can give it an image and ask it
questions uh that requires a little bit
reasoning and you can prompt this with
with let's think step by step which is
um a technique used to elicit reasoning
in large language models but here in
multimodal language models you can do
the same I guess people also are also
experimenting it uh these days with gbt
4V you can also prompt it to think step
by step or count row by row uh but here
um this is before gbt 4V and we were
able to elicit reasoning using some of
the interesting prompts such as we can
ask it uh in this photo um are there
more cats or more dogs let's think step
by step and they found the the pal me
found out there are equal amount of dogs
and cats and on the right um given image
can I go down the street on a bicycle
yes or no let's think step by step and
the reply is do not enter second except
the bicycles do not entry except the
bicycles yes so it's doing this mod of
reasoning and it's mixing um this
understanding of symbols and also mixing
the understanding of text so this is
quite quite amazing to me
uh to be to be honest when I first saw
this I didn't expect a multi mod
language model would be able to do that
and uh we also tried one thing which is
traditionally very difficult to to uh to
language models which is to tell a joke
language models can understand joke but
sometimes it just doesn't it's not able
to tell you a joke um like when it comes
to the punch line because it's just
trying to make something that is
plausible and sounds like a joke and
when there it comes to the punchline it
doesn't really know what to say so here
I give it an image and I ask it to come
come up with a description and then come
comes up with a joke so this guide
language model to think step by step and
the description is a donkey is carrying
a dog cat and rooster and the joke is
what do you call a donkey with a rooster
on his back a rooster booster um it's so
creative like when I saw this I'm I'm
pleasantly uh surprised and I searched
online I couldn't find another joke like
that so it's actually original joke by
pomy and finally we see some math
reasoning with this model um um
basically I give it a messy manual from
a pizza store and I ask it um how much
is a I'm just buying a pizza for me and
my friend how much should I pay let's
think step by step and it's figuring out
there's a pizza and there's a $9.99 and
it tell you the price uh in some of the
answers it even calculate text but text
but the text is hallucinated so that
doesn't
work all right let's talk about positive
transfer so apart from the amazing capab
amazing um uh things that py can do it
also has interesting positive transfer
Behavior so um when we train P me on a
single domain when we train it on just a
single robotics task the performance is
not super great but when we pull all the
data together and we also include uh
internet SC SC um Vision language tasks
such as captioning or Vision visual
question answering it is able to do much
better so this shows that it's important
to mix all the data together and train
it jointly the internet scale data can
uh can act as a a regularizer for you to
not forget the
representations and those
representations are in turn very useful
for
robotics so that's that's a POS transfer
results and we start to see more and
more positive transfer in other of our
studies yes so how much to colletive
like in simulation or in real world like
I think the like the playing with the
Sorting stuff on the table is very
impressive right yeah that's that's a
very good point so um for the for the
for the so these are all planning data
like high level planning um it is um so
so so maybe let's let's just talk about
two things so first of all the the
Sorting results um the lowlevel policy
is still using uh a traditional
controller so it's using a policy called
lava and that policy is trained down 68
uh thousand episodes um the high level
planning is probably easier than you
think because it it only need to tell um
so put the it's given command to the low
LEL policy so it's basically only need
to
um put the red block into top left
corner put another red block into top
left corner so it's rather a quite
Standard Auto regressive um Auto
regressive like language modeling task
the only thing you need to do is to
determine what task is not finished yet
so for example if the block is already
in a corner it shouldn't call Lo of
policy to move it to the corner again so
it's it's rather like understand parsing
the states and understanding the states
so this high level policy only requires
about like 50 to 100 demonstrations to
learn so it's quite parameter efficient
and in the future that's a very good
question actually in the future a lot of
uh these tasks can be taught in context
so maybe we just demonstrate it once to
the large language model then it knows
how to do
that how can how can the language model
know like like which
level this
is yeah this is through human
demonstration as well so human human on
a low level can demonstrate low level
policy by T operating a robot to do a
certain task but on a high level it
could also um it could also just uh give
the low policy like imagine your control
interface is through text and then you
can you as a human you can also guide a
low Lev policy to accomplish a task and
then nothing thing uh can can then be
used to to train a large language model
so that's for the Sorting sorting block
the second is a little bit more
interesting because the planning steps
are actually generated by pal so we
essentially distilled pal plus this
affordance model into pal e so that
that's that's a little bit more
interesting that's like using the AI
data to boost strap itself that that
that uh that one has about 3,000
episodes also not not quite a lot U but
it's able to learn complex planning
Behavior replanning behavor your error
recovery which I will show in this slide
so with the paly as a high level planner
we are able to do um pick the take the
rice chips out of the
drawer and uh there is a Twist which is
um I will be messing with the robot and
so as it put onto the onto counter I put
it back to the drawer and as it uh um
pick it up again and then I put it back
again so it's able to understand the
state it's able to understand my task is
not finished I cannot proceed with the
next task now after I don't mess it with
mess with it anymore it's able to close
a drawer and pick up the the bag of
chips so um Tomy is able to combine
affordance and planning in one model and
do uh complex reasoning of of the scene
and
environment and interestingly we can use
the exact same model checkpoint to do
block sorting as well so this is the
same model chech point it can not only
reason about how to bring a b of chips
to a user it can also th blocks so and
it's also responding to a theal uh
peration like if the user is uh putting
the Block in the middle again it's able
to recover from that so these are all
coming from the same model and it can
also tell
joke
so yeah this is the power of like uh uh
like Vis Vision language models uh now
we want to go a level deeper like these
are all Vision language models that are
used for planning or high level
reasoning can we use them for low LEL
control it turns out we can we can um
and that's the rt2 work which is Vision
language action model that transfer web
knowledge to robotic control what can I
do when when asked uh pick up the uh EX
tin animal and it has a whole range of
objects on the table it will pick up the
dinosaur so it can link the extinct
animal to dinosaur and to the action
that pick the dinosaur up so it's really
doing like this this emergent reasoning
and also the manipulation in just the
one model and by the way uh this robot
hasn't seen any of these before in at
least in the robot training data it it
might have seen this in the internet
catalog right but it has never seen it
in the um in the robotics training data
so uh it's it's quite interesting how we
need to evaluate these robot nowadays um
so in U when we evaluate language models
to prevent uh data contamination every
time you need to give it new questions
because otherwise it might already in
memorize it in in its training when we
evaluate this robots we actually go to
Dollar Store dollar store to buy all
these toys to make sure it hasn't seen
that before and as we run more
evaluation maybe there will be some
replication as well but as you can see
it is able to understand um to pick up
this dinosaur
toy um how do we do that how did we do
that so we start from a vision language
model that is trained on internet scale
data and then we also combine it with
robotics action data uh which is the rt1
data and we get rt2 and u we can dive
deeper a little bit deeper into into A2
so first what is a vision language Model
A Vision language model is a Transformer
is a Transformer that take in image and
text and then output text so um we
uh within Google there's a ver language
model called P which is encoder decoder
type of architecture it's basically
having a viit to understand images and
then a Transformer encoder um and the
Transformer
decoder um they Encompass both the
visual and semantics to understand the
world and in robotics we have to deal
with a lot of both of these and the
question is can we leverage the
knowledge in the the the the uh Vision
language models and apply them to
robotics on the other hand we have the
it1 uh if you want to learn more about
rt1 you can listen to the previous um um
episode of this cs25 by T so he give a
detailed introduction on rt1 but the rt1
is if you stand far enough um it is also
a vision
language to action or something model
right it takes in a human instruction it
takes in the current camera image the
camera image pass through a film
efficient net which is tokenized into 81
tokens and then going to a token learner
which compress everything into eight
tokens and then there is a Transformer
block leveraging a lot of self intention
layer and then generate actions the
action is also tokenized uh the robot
have a um seven degree of
Freedom um basically the the the and
Factor has six degree of Freedom it's
position and rotation and the Grier can
open and close and there's another um
Dimension representing terminate the
episode or not terminating means my task
is is already done and we discretize
every um Dimension into 256 bins and
then we do crossentropy loss on those
bins so that's a rt1 architecture in a
nutshell it's it's it's surp it's quite
similar to a vision language model with
different output tokens so it's rather
natural that we just use a large
pretrained Vision language model
directly as policy we can use the pi or
Pal as a
policy and one question is how do we
deal with actions when using pre-trained
uh Vision language models and here is
action representation that we use um the
robot actions here are the eight uh
dimensions and as I mentioned there's
termination position change and rotation
change and we discretize everything into
2 256 bins we also have tried other
alternative representations but they are
not as good as just this like naive
representation
yes yeah
yeah what is film effici oh the film
efficient net is a pretrained
convolutional neural network it's used
to tokenize the images so the reason
that we do this is um through some
ablation study we can tokenize the image
in different ways we can tokenize in
rest net we can tokenize everything into
rest net and we can tokenize using film
efficient net film what it means is it
also take into the language embedding
and append it to the inter the layers of
the of the rest net so we basically have
like yeah that goes through
this that's right that's
right action that's right is action as
in code the action is not in code the
action is is in a is in text is in like
basically what is shown here like this
is the
action
it's eight numbers each number range
from 0 to
255 yeah and and maybe another note on
the film rest net it's about how we
tokenize the images and how we combine
um Vision information and language
information there are many ways to do
that this is not the only way there is
early fusion and late fusion and there
is also cross attention you can
basically tokenize your image just by
itself and then you can have Lang and
you use cross attention to combine the
image and text representation so here we
are using the this this model this is
it1 for robotics so we do have a lot of
considerations such as latency that's
why we use this film resonant because
it's super fast and it can output
limited amount of tokens which we can
further compress with token learner yeah
yeah and this like aive like every
sing right so it is agressive yeah and
every time we use history of up to six
six steps so every time you see this
image right now and you see about two
seconds of History before before it and
um this will be the your your
input yeah again if you have more
questions about rt1 I recommend watching
the uh previous episode
um and U and here is all about rt2 so we
can convert the the string of numbers um
this will be our output of our
Transformer uh which is a vision
language model we tried other
Alternatives uh such as floating numbers
floating numbers is not super friendly
to language model tokenizer because uh
it has this decimal points we also tried
the human language such as left or right
it's more semantic representation but
they cannot be directly executed on
robot which is liation of this
method um so if we commit to this action
representation which is just a string of
numbers we essentially get a vision
language action model we tried different
variants including polyx um this is a
Pathways language and image model uh it
can um there are five billion parameters
variant and 55 billion parameter variant
and we also tried P me which is 12
billion
parameters the the procedure that we did
um to train this altit is via coine
tuning
coine tuning is to put the internet
scale data and the robotic data together
and then we fine tune it um on this
mixture of data so that it doesn't it
retains the internet scale
knowledge um maybe that's also an
artifact of our data is too small and
not diverse enough so if you just a fine
tune on robotics data it will quickly
overfit and forgot about um all this
paining mixture uh maybe it's it's a
dynamic of scale so so uh we'll
see uh at inference time how do we do
this uh we basically we again we do this
Auto regressively we have a an
instruction um of um task and we format
this as a question and answering task uh
what should the robot do to achieve a
certain task and the task is a strin
that human give the robot for the robot
to achieve and it also have the current
observation um which is the um
which is the um U robot observation the
camera image RGB image it pass through
AIT and then it pass through the large
language model and then output uh a list
of tokens so we leverage constraint
decoding to make sure it always have
eight numbers um and um because
otherwise we cannot DET toonize it it's
very easy for language model to just
miss one number right so we do have some
mechanism uh such as constraint the
decoding and beam search to make sure
the format is correct after we get a
string of a numbers we DET toonize it to
a delta T and Delta R which is the and
effector Delta post and the robot can
just directly run this on the robot
after it run on the robot we repeat this
process we get another New Image run
through this process and get a new
action and we repeat this process until
a termination is decoded so um some
people might be concerned that this is
rather slow um it's it's in fact quite
slow uh because it's a 12 12 billion
parameters or five billion parameters uh
we cannot run on a robot so we run on a
TP cluster and the robot is quiring the
TP cluster to get the numbers and apply
it uh on on the robot so for the 12
billion parameters we can actually run
at 10 Hertz so it's quite fast for all
of model we can run at at least three
Hertz so that is that is sufficient for
uh controlling a Rob
robot and we see a lot of emerging
skills that is not trained um that is
not on the training set essentially uh
as I just mentioned we are probing what
this rt2 can do we actually don't know
so we are trying to figure out what rt2
can do so we we we test it with a lot of
new tasks such as put a strawberry into
the correct bow or move banana to
Germany like just to test its
understanding of symbols or Flags um
pick land animal uh there's a horse
there's octopus basically tested
semantic reasoning and also uh low level
manipulation
skills and we uh divide the the tasks
into simple understanding and reasoning
and human recognition and average we
found that uh with rt1 which is not
trained on internet scale data we we do
quite poorly in this emerging evaluation
tasks and uh in uh in the um rt2
variance which is co coine tuned on the
internet data and on robotics data we do
much better in these tasks and there is
also um effect of scale so the R2 with a
55 billion po um is performing better
than the 12 billion py although they
perform quite similarly for IND domain
tasks so but the the generalization is
kind of interesting it seems uh with
larger scale you can
better and here are some videos of the
robot um achieving these tasks like
moving the banana to a number put the
strawberry in into the correct bow move
move a Rubik's Cube to the water bottle
but I'm speaking Chinese um moving the
banana to a German flag so it's able to
do all all of these very interesting
tasks uh in terms of the quantitative
evaluations uh we also found that um the
altitude policy is quite robust to
unseeing objects unseeing backgrounds
and unseeing
environments and here is another
evidence of positive transfer so coine
tune with vqa data outperforms fine
tuning on robotics only and if you're
train on robot data from scratch it it
barely works it almost doesn't work
because it overfits to robot data and
our robot data is just too small so we
do need uh to um do Co fine tuning or at
least the fine tuning so it retains its
internet skill knowledge this is also a
recipe for how people would develop a
domain specific Vision language model so
you start from a very General Vision
language model and you find you on your
domain or you can coine tune with with
your your specific domain data this is
likely a problem that each vertical of
uh artificial intelligence would uh
would uh incur
someday uh we can also test on other
platforms like this shows some cross
embodiment the rt2 PO 3B outperforms
previous models in terms of moving
blocks around a TOD
environment so this is um and and in
large language models we have this Chain
of Thought reasoning which is um a
method to elicit reasoning in in large
language models um you can either do
zero short CH of thought reasoning by
say less thing step by step I'll give it
examples of reasoning is is basically
decoding more things and then come to
the conclusion we can uh use a similar
procedure for um the rt2 as well so in
rt2 P me instead of directly decoding
the actions we can actually decode a
plan and then aend it with actions so
this gives the language model and
opportunity to understand a question or
par a question differently it also giv
us the the opportunity to reason about
things a little bit for example if
you'll say uh bring me a drink and it
will say pick up seven up can because
there's a seven up can on the on the
table so we synthesized a couple hundred
such examples using a large language
model just by argumenting the
instruction and then fine tune the ait2
just for a couple hundred steps so it's
between full fine-tuning and Inc context
learning and is able to do some
reasoning and some of the interesting
reasoning tasks include I need to hammer
a nail Which object from the scene might
be useful and in the scene there is a a
headphone there is a rock and there is a
sticky note and the robot will say rocks
and then generate actions to pick up the
rock so it's interesting that it's able
to do this of reasoning with with it2
and here is a demonstration of some of
the Chain of Thought reasoning with it2
P me and the task is pick up the thing
that is different from all other objects
um and it pick up the the the chocolate
because this is a snack and other things
are the drink and I can also speak a
different language and the plan would be
to translate it into a language that is
familiar with which is English and then
do the
task um there are also potentially
failure case of the Chain of Thought
reasoning so here I say move the green
object together and as you can see the
robot oscillates between the two green
objects because there are rather two
plants it could move the the can to the
back of chips or it could move the back
of chips to the can uh it oscillates
between two plant until uh one action
bring it to an object and it will commit
to one of a plan rather than another
it's not always guaranteed to work but
it's quite interesting and it's also
interesting that again we are testing
the manipulation policy like how we test
intelligence of human or animals or kids
um because they they're they're getting
more and more
advanced um as a summary we have the
vision language and action model um that
is able to achieve improve improve the
generalization it can do new tasks and
operate new objects it can also do Chain
of Thought reasoning and improving the
underlying model um such as the the
vision language model Itself by scaling
it up um and um trained with internet
scale data or trained with larger or
higher quality internet scale data we
can achieve better robot control which
is quite amazing because robotics field
has been traditionally developing quite
slowly and is bounded by Hardware
bounded by a lot of different things
bounded by operation but now it seems we
can piggyback on the development of the
foundation model field and whatever they
do will trickle down to our field as
well and the future will be to increase
the motion diversity and extent uh on
the Chain of Thought reasoning
capability and many
more and uh um so there's another
example of positive transfer which you
you might have seen recently uh so so
far I've been talking about uh scaling
differently right I've been talking
about don't scale robotics data um and
scale other data that's because robotics
data data is so hard to collect and and
the purpose is not to avoid collecting
robotics data it's to uh develop a
recipe that you can do more with limited
robotics data however there's also an
effort from our team and the the entire
robotics field uh to scale up the robot
data collection which is called the open
X embodiment and the model train is
called RTX robotics Transformer X it's
basically 22 type of embodiments and two
uh 57 two skills and 60 data sets pulled
all together so this will be the
ultimate data set we can use to study
positive transfer and the scale to to
study this joint
scaling and um there are already
evidences of uh positive transfer so um
we pulled all the data together from all
these labs and find a common action
representation that we can use to train
a robotic Transformer and we have
already found this a jointly trained
model can outperform task specific model
uh that is developed in in each of the
lab so there is some benefits in pulling
all the data together so um scaling
robot data is also quite
important so the summary for this part
is that we are having a model
consolidation we can now do the high
level reasoning and load of control in
one model and the load of control part
is what excites me because it's so far
away from the traditional language model
U domain it's it's it's so different and
it so shows science of life that we can
trickle down a lot more than we used to
think uh is possible and we can scale
the pre-training of vision language
models as well as scaling robotics data
and we observe more and more positive
transfer a model benefiting from diverse
joint training across internet scale
language vision and vision language
domains all right so um I noticed that
we are close to running out of time so I
will just very quickly go through the
second part which I think is also
interesting it is to find new interfaces
of language models but I would only talk
at a very high level uh so language
models as we can see can directly output
action tokens if we found action
representation so we can treat action as
yet another language to the language
model so language model can do
translation so it should be able to
generate action as well but that
requires f
can we do can we do it without fine
tuning or can we generate more
expressive actions that is beyond this
the scope of fine tuning so um that is
about finding the right interface so
previously we have already established
that language model doesn't have an
action interface if it has an action
interface it's it's not as
effective so what is the best interface
between language and low LEL actions I
would argue the best interface um
between language model and the Loos loo
actions is reward functions and reward
functions is universal it it has been
used in reinforcement learning and it's
also a repar
reparameterization of actions what is
action let me let's see if I want to
pick up this uh bottle and I can say
what what is a skill a skill is a
mapping between my observation and my
action so the mapping between my
observation and action can be seen as a
scale
but a skill can have alternative
definition which is a set of constraints
and a set of objectives so picking up
the bottle means the bottle is in my
right hand and the bottle is off is off
a supporting surface that means picking
up and how do I pick it up doesn't
really matter uh that's a more kind of
uh to its broader sense a definition of
skills it's more transferable between
different different
skills and um that and the constraints
and objectives can be represented as
rewards so we can ask language model to
generate these reward functions and then
uh there's Optimizer it could be
reinforced learning or it could be model
predictive control uh that optimize for
those rewards and then um run it on the
robot so what is in the reward
translator it is uh let's let's open a
box so the reward translator basically
is is a two-stage process it's using the
same language model and it is using two
different prompts so the motion
description basically describes the the
motion so just now we we found that the
language model can can output a
description of how a robot doc should
stand up but it's not able to achieve
that but the the motion description is
still sensible it still makes sense it
gives you the right thing so we're just
a like generate this motion description
and then we have a reward translator
reward coder that translate this motion
description into a piece of code uh that
is uh representing that is representing
reward
functions and these reward functions
cannot be directly executed on the robot
but it can go through a optimization
process to to learn how to achieve those
reward functions so we're using reward
as the the interface between language
model and a lot of controller and for
the low controller we're using modal MPC
which is a model predicted control uh
model predict control algorithm it's
basically uh a blackbox controller it
samples a lot of tra trajectories and
find one that optimize your
reward and we test it on a robot dog a
quadr robot essentially and a dextrus
manipulator so the dextrus manipulator
has an arm of six or seven degree of
freedom and a hand um it's impossible to
control it because it has so many degre
Freedom so um it's highly um challenging
so just to Showcase some of the examples
I admitted the motion description part I
only output the um the uh reward code
part so it seems that the language model
is able to generate the right reward
functions to make the robot stand up on
two back feet like a
human all right and then now we are a
little bit more ambitious like we know
it can stand up uh can we make the robot
do a moon walk while standing up like
this so moonwalk is from Michael Jackson
and it's very challenging how do we make
the robot to do it so it generate the
motion description and gener the reward
code but the motion is uh not not so
correct not exactly what we want the
nice thing about using a language model
and using the reward function is that
you can coach the robot you can go back
and explain what went wrong and ask the
language model to fix it so now we can
actually say you're you're you're being
very patient you say moonwalk means a
robot should mo mo walk backward while
the feet swing as if they are moving
forward uh such a such a great uh
explanation kudos to my colleague and
correct your answer and also make it
work at a speed of 0.5 meters per second
and after you like being very patient
and give it the right instruction it's
able to modify the reward the motion
descriptor descriptor and also generate
the right set of rewards to make this
happen and now you can teach robot to do
moonwalk just by using the language as
an
interface and one day we'll be able to
do this on the real robot as well yes so
previous section you show
how numbers and your constra them toate
numbers here how do you prevent it from
Just
hallucinating right so uh that's a great
question um in in in this work we are
not preventing it hallucination to do
hallucination in a programmatic way we
have a a set of system prompts or a set
of rules that is explaining the API
after all the reward functions need to
be able to be compiled by the optimizer
and then like uh after yeah so we do
need to have some check uh what's more
if it doesn't compile we can just give
the error message to the language model
it doesn't have to propagate all the way
to the motion descriptor it can stay at
the reward coder if there are errors
please fix it so after that you should
be able to fix
it um we can also chain multiple tasks
together uh using this framework we can
say open the drawer uh take the the
Apple put it into the drawer and close
the drawer and it's it will be able to
do that so we tried that just using
reward coder is not good enough it's
rather our two-stage prompt is us really
really helpful uh I think that's another
inspiration for other fields like when
your domain is too different from
language domain maybe it would be good
to find an intermediate representation
and ask the language model to explain in
that intermediate representation before
directly go to a more obscure uh
representation and uh uh finally we want
to transfer this to the real world but
but there is a challenge in simulation
it might generate actions that are too
dextrous like this um this uh uh this
thing is not possible to do in the real
world so
we add a few more regular Riser terms to
stabilize the motion and we also run
some State estimation on the real robot
so that they um they understand uh where
is the the cubes and then we can in the
simulation grab the motion and then
achieve it in the real world so here are
some of the execution in the real world
so you can say pick up the Rubik's Cube
and it will generate the motion to pick
up the Rubik SCP and this is quite
different from rt2 the motion are quite
smooth um it's uh it's quite fast it's
much faster than uh three Herz so here
it can do 10 Hertz or even uh even 30
Hertz so it's comparable with
human all right so that's a language to
reward there's one last thing that I
want to talk about in terms of finding
the a new interface so a lot of time we
have been thinking about language model
as a semantic engine a semantic machine
it understands semantics so for example
you say the the the student takes out
the student takes out the book you will
say book like language model is able to
reason about such a sequence but if you
do lowlevel patterns like if you just
give it the Obscure numbers can you do
what can you do like it's it's actually
a lowlevel interface and we can open up
the lowle interface to uh off language
model and ask it to do robotics tasks so
in this paper large language language
model model as general pattern machines
we explore using the lowlevel interface
of a large language model essentially
asking it to reason about different
sequences and is surprisingly quite
effective and it can solve tasks like
the The Arc Challenge and the pcfg um
and it can even do sequence Improvement
so I will dig a little bit into sequence
Improvement because that's quite
relevant to robotics so sequence
Improvement is that you prompt the
language model with State action and
reward tupos and you Pro just prompt it
with higher reward and see if it can
generate actions that achieve the higher
reward so it's doing reinforc learning
or reinforc learning like thing but in
context so this is quite amazing so
previously you would need a a dedicated
algorithm collecting data replay buffer
to do this reinforc learning but now you
can just build everything in the
language model context by leveraging the
lowle interface of a language
model and with that we can actually do
something like clicker training so if
you're are not very familiar with
clicker training is how you can do you
can U you can have a dog and you you can
um when it does the right thing you give
it a reward by by right so you can uh so
the clicker training is um giving the
the agent a reward and uh we we can now
use clicker training to train robots as
well so here uh the robot is exploring
but I would give click it does the right
thing or towards the right direction and
over time uh it will be able to push the
back of chips which is the objective of
this training so you can do this entire
uh decision Transformer like operation
but purely in context by just give the
language Model A bunch of patterns and
ask you to figure out what is what is
what is the regularity of this sequence
and this way it can generate new actions
to improve previous
sequence all right uh um so for the
language model uh we can find new
interfaces that are more uh suitable for
teaching it low level skills uh reward
is a bridge and of language model and
low level control and we can fully
leverage it as a universal interface and
you can optimize in real
time um sometimes it outperforms
generating action directly so it uh
really motivates to use the uh reward
functions as interface and the language
model as a general pattern machines we
can use language model beyond the
semantic tasks we can ask it to reason
low level things and also robotics as a
do domain Rich of sequence
transformation and sequence completion
and sequence Improvement tasks so we can
really study the the lower level
mechanisms of language
models and the key takeaway is that um
for for this talk is that we are seeing
more and more use of foundation models
not only on the semantic reasoning side
side of Robotics but more on the dextrus
on the generating actions on the lower
level embod embod and intelligence side
of Robotics and we can we need to
rethink the scaling law of Robotics and
Transformer how do we scale it with
limited amount of data we have a new
recipe for scaling robot model and data
in rt2 which shows that you can do more
with the same data with essentially rt1
data plus internet data you can
generalize to a lot more things in RTX
shows that you can do a lot more with
more data there is also benefits to
collecting more robotics data and
there's positive transfers everywhere
and apart to uh in terms of new
interfaces for language models I think
it's worth uh for the robotics field to
think about developing new and lower
level interface to language models which
facilitate uh learning low level skills
with that I I would like to conclude my
talk and if you find it interesting
there are a lot of references for you to
to uh look into and special thanks to my
team uh Google mind Robo robotics team
so we're at a Forefront of developing
Foundation models for Robotics and stay
tuned for more in the future thank
you yes you mentioned that FL numbers
are difficult for large language model
but if you're just generating the action
tokens like no you know no rocks or
whatever you had an example why don't
you just have like linear layer appended
to the you the Transformer that just
numbers
from whatever yeah the the question is
that uh um if the if we are uh the large
language models have difficulty
understanding numbers why don't we use a
linear layer to outut the action
directly I think so language models are
difficult to understand numbers but
sometimes we still want it to kind of
bring in Knowledge from the pre-training
mixture
like if if um I want if I have a new
layer like that that new layer is not
present in the pre training so how do I
expect it to transfer I think that's
that's an interesting question but at
the same time I don't necessarily think
using the raw numbers is a right
interface there we probably could do
some action representation learning to
learn a representation and the language
model can output that representation so
we're still trying to figure out what is
the uh right representation
so among the representations that we
have tried before like decimal numbers
Flo numbers uh extra tokens we find just
using numbers or actual tokens would be
would be good
enough
yes
pring yeah um I think both directions
are are worth exploring there are
different advantages of generating like
generating action directly I think it's
it it borrows the auto regressive nature
of like um language modeling and it's it
aligns with a lot of other tasks like
visual question answering really well
the limitation is that then uh when
you're generating actions it's heavily
regularized can you generate dextrous
actions that is so out of distribution
that is kind of difficult the language
to reward actually brings a a page of
the book of traditional robotics like
right this optimization based or model
predicted control so and you can also
take into let's say safety constraints
uh more more more easily it can generate
more diverse actions maybe one recipe is
to generate a lot of data with the
language to reward system and distill
them into a Transformer because then
you're imbuing your large language model
with all this other desirable uh the
language through World itself I don't
know how scalable it is like it's we're
not fine tuning language model so maybe
you are limited to what the uh you are
at the mercy of the training data of the
language model the language model can do
uh moonwalk because it it knows what
moonwalk is it roughly knows how that uh
like how to do that
but if you want to scale to completely
new things maybe you can use the
language to world to boost drop your
data generation and then put into like
the other
policy
okay what's the next directions gos it's
like the language
the yeah I think that's a good question
so this the scaling the the scaling
being the end of the lecture uh that has
a joke but as as I'm I'm being quite
serious like it's actually a promising
recipe so uh we have been we have been
um everybody is believing in the power
of the scaling rule so just by giving it
more data giving it more compute you
will see interesting kind of
capabilities coming out yeah Al gb2 GB
big J so do you think like we ready for
robotics to have that Chum we can you
see the cap yeah um I still I still
think we are not quite like we don't
quite have enough data I think that's
still probably the biggest bottleneck so
we are trying to find ways to do more
with limited data and we are trying to
collect more data and I think it needs
some time for for us to accumulate
enough data and currently I say uh we
have science of life for positive
transfer but in in language models
people don't talk about positive
transfers anymore because it's so common
place right you you see it everywhere um
and robot robotics is not at that stage
yet yeah how much is your te thinking
about safety and Alignment yeah are you
just like right now like relying on kind
of the ethics that emerge from the large
language models like it won't you know
tell you to kill to achieve yeah that's
a very good question actually we take
safety very very seriously because all
of the the domains of developing
language models um it doesn't have
direct like impact on on the physical
world but here like um it could have
potential harm to to human and to the
environment and Gary Marcus actually
give a comment to previously to our work
that what if you say U bring bring out a
bow feed the cat and put it in the
dishwasher where it put the cat in the
dishwasher right if it misunderstand
actually it will have a a catastrophic
uh um failure case um we we take uh
safety carefully by designing like
hardware and software safety layers and
uh there are also some constitutional
like safety um uh thing that is coming
out sometime soon I cannot tell much
details right now but uh sometime soon
we releas some work is it something like
if there's a human like just don't
interact well know I think it's a little
bit more nuanced and more detailed than
that yeah but we do take safety quite
seriously and in some of our experiments
actually the robot finger would break
off because it cannot apply enough Force
to an environment so that's just yet
another way of ensuring
safety can we have some like Vis
mod and maybe this is kind of like but
right right yeah I think it it would be
possible thank you for cool
cool